bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
dernier rendez vous de la semaine que
j'aimerais dédier à la mémoire de serge
dassault
l'actionnaire du figaro disparu lundi
dernier à qui un hommage national est
rendu en ce moment même aux invalides en
présence du premier ministre je vous
propose de découvrir tout de suite le
sommaire de cette émission nous allons
commencer par parler de l'italie puisque
enfin le gouvernement est formé avec
giuseppe compter les représentants de la
ligue et du mouvement 5 étoiles
ce nouveau gouvernement et tire une
menace pour l'europe vous lui donnerez
votre point de vue on va parler aussi du
changement de nom du front national qui
va désormais s'appeler le rassemblement
national est ce que ça le dédiabolise
selon l'expression consacrée
nous en parlerons et qu on parlera aussi
des réactions européenne et en
particulier française après l'annoncé
par donald trump de taxation sur l'acier
en provenance d'une européenne aussi du
mexique ou du canada
emmanuel macron at il raison de se poser
en défenseur du libre échange où est-il
en retard d'une guerre
et puis on va aussi revenir sur cette
polémique qui n'en finit pas la
déclaration de gérard collomb le
ministre de l'intérieur c'était mercredi
avant-hier il a parlé de benchmarking
pour expliquer que les migrants
choisissez avec soin leur destination en
europe
est ce une déclaration choquante nous en
parlerons avec nos quatre invités
bonsoir judith waintraub vous êtes grand
reporter au figaro magazine
benjamin granger là aussi bonsoir
pourquoi vous êtes président de dentsu
consulting et directeur général de
dentsu aegis france bonsoir richard
bouygues heureux de vous accueillir dans
cette émission vous êtes à un expert
surtout dans les sujets de sport et de
sociétés à la fondation jean jaurès vous
êtes aussi premier adjoint socialiste à
la mairie du 12e arrondissement de paris
vous êtes le coauteur d'un livre qui
vient de sortir il ya quelques jours
qu'ils appellent le foot va-t-il
exploser aux éditions de l'aube et à la
fondation jean jaurès
et puis adrien mathoux et là aussi
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste politique
à l'hebdomadaire marianne
nos confrères de marianne qui
ce week-end sorte une couverture non pas
sur l'héritage chers amis car ça c'est
moi que c'était vendredi dernier mais
adriana tout va nous dire lui-même la
une de son magazine ce week-end les
marchés décident du sort de l'europe et
donc de l'italie exactement et ben
l'italie parlons-en justement habile
transition tient au cp kanté est donc le
nouveau président du conseil italien
il ya dans ce gouvernement le patron du
mouvement 5 étoiles luigi di maio qui
est vice président du conseil et
ministre du développement économique
matteo salvini aussi le patron de la
ligue l'ex ligue du nord et là aussi les
ministres de l'intérieur et paolo
cerveau n'a et puis on arrêterait la
dans la liste des ministres vous savez
c'est cet homme qui devait être ministre
de l'économie mais qui était ouvertement
anti euro et on a recasé au ministère au
ministère oui des affaires européennes
alors est ce que ce gouvernement est
encore dangereux pour l'europe
écouter les déclarations très prudentes
faite par le ministre des affaires
étrangères français monsieur jean yves
le drian c'était hier soir sur lci
il faut respecter leur vote ils ont fait
leur choix
il faut qu'il le mène jusqu'à son
jusqu'à l'aude jusqu'à son terme et le
président matériel a proposé la
composition d'un gouvernement il a pris
ses responsabilités aussi je pense qu'il
ne faut pas porter de jugement parce que
nous avons besoin de l'italie l'europe
doit être au rendez vous des
interrogations des italiens un bateau en
101 gouvernement français très prudent
et pourtant en réalité il ya une vraie
inquiétude en europe
oui parce que d'abord emmanuel macron
avait félicité sergio matériel à quand
il s'était opposé à la formation précise
lydie troyenne quand il s'était opposé à
la formation du premier gouvernement
italien ensuite on voit qu'ils nous
voient un petit peu parce qu'il ya eu
des réactions
outre et ce qui s'était passé mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que le gouvernement
italien qui vient d'être formé il est
élu sur la promesse de remettre en cause
l'ordre économique de l'union européenne
donc forcément il aura confrontation
judith waintraub en même temps le
l'homme qui posait problème et qui fait
que le président matin j'en parlais à
l'instant avait refusé le gouvernement
s'était amusé de l'économie qui
voulaient sortir de l'euro le nouveau
lui il n'est pas anti euro donc est-ce
que c'est rassurant
ça change pas fondamentalement la nature
du problème au sens où effectivement le
programme comptait lui les italiens en
donnant leur voix à la ligue et à son
partenaire est incompatible avec
l'europe telle qu'elle est donc
évidemment le problème va se poser il
semblerait que comme en france
d'ailleurs
il ya un décalage entre l'adhésion que
suscitent les partis souverainistes et
l'opinion des gens sur faut-il rester
dans l'euro ou le quitter et puis leur
enquête en italie qui semblait indiquer
que le mouvement en faveur d'un départ
de l'euro n'était pas si nette que ça ça
explique aussi peut-être la prudence des
nouveaux arrivants le benjamin quand
vous êtes souvent le l'analyste la vigie
de cette émission sur les réseaux
sociaux
bon ce n'est pas un sujet français est
ce qu'on en parle quand même est-ce que
ça suscite de l'intérêt
alors si globalement on parle beaucoup
de l'italie oui mais on parle surtout de
l'italie par rapport aux france italie 2
ce soir match amical oggero bref
beaucoup de conversation c'est presque
cette semaine 50 % de conversation de
plus que la semaine dernière de ses
presque 100 96 milles conversation s'est
effectivement énorme maintenant au
milieu de ça oui on parle du sujet
de ce nouveau gouvernement et finalement
on en parle de deux manières la première
en challenge eu terriblement la
compétence du nouveau premier ministre
qui finalement est peut-être un juriste
émérite mais en tout cas nous on n'a pas
montré de compétences ou de faits
d'armes particulier quant à la paix
quand voilà c'est quand allah allah à la
gestion d'un domaine en tout cas d'un
domaine où d'un ou d'un gouvernement ou
d'un sujet public d'ailleurs personne ne
le connaissait il ya des jours quand
quand les camps les gagnants les
élections d'en sortir et la peau et y
compris en italie exactement et puis
surtout ce qui ce qui marque que les
conversations c'est cette interrogation
sur la montée du populisme et finalement
tout le monde se dit mais non l'euro
n'est pas le comment dire la libye a de
tous les problèmes les migrants non plus
et donc l'interrogation des français qui
est très marquée dans les conversations
suite à cette nomination c'est pourquoi
cette montée du populisme
eh ben elle imprime temps elle imprime
temps aujourd'hui avec comme
illustration finalement ce qu'on vit en
italie
alors chers internautes vous le savez
cette émission est la vôtre et vous
n'avez pas attendu ce commentaire pour
le savoir vous donnez vos réactions sur
twitter hashtag figaro life hashtag
point de vue sur lefigaro.fr et voici
les premiers commentaires il faut
respecter le vote des italiens nous dit
crépy bruxelles se moquent du peuple et
de son opinion j'appelle ça du
despotisme à lens à bruxelles c'était
les déclarations des commissaires
européens ou en tout cas de l'un d'entre
eux qui expliquait que les troubles
économiques possibles à les faire
revenir les italiens dans le droit
chemin
l'italie enfin un gouvernement choisi
par ces italiens nous dit agostina qui
thériault nous écrit en italien et donc
mais on note grand voyant offrir à fear
alive donc on a traduit en simultané et
et alexandre nous dit ça finira en
message de froch comme chypre à ce point
d'interrogation
alors ça c'est pas en italien
apparemment en existe toujours reposé
comme la grande-bretagne alors la
question d'alexandre est intéressante on
se souvient qu effectivement type race
avait été nommé premier ministre en
grèce ou pour la sur la promesse d'une
politique en rupture avec l'europe et
finalement ça s'était pas fait mais
revenons à l'italie
richard briques votre analyse sur ce qui
est en train de se passer mais je crois
qu'il ya un fait majeur et qu'on va
revoir dans pleins d'élections en europe
c'est que à la disparition d'un clivage
qu'on appelait gauche droite un peu
traditionnelle on voit qu'on a un autre
clivage qui s'est aujourd'hui dessinée
qui est celui un peu de systèmes anti
système politique autoritaire pas
politique autoritaire
aujourd'hui on a un gouvernement qui est
légitimement élu le principe
constitutionnel a bien fonctionné et je
crois qu'il faut respecter ça après il
ya la promesse la promesse notamment
économiques avec des montants proposés
pour relancer la machine et investir
avec pas d'impôts à côté ce qui est en
fait le programme un peu commun de cette
alliance originale mais les finances
publiques mais oui mais qui en fait
interroge quand même quant à sa
possibilité à sa nature et en même temps
on le dit l'italie est un des acteurs
majeurs de la construction européenne
est aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est un
chamboulement parce que cet acteur là
vient un peu titillé ce qui est
aujourd'hui l'acte fondateur encore de
l'europe et est ce que l'europe a encore
un sens est-ce qu'il faut la remodeler
ou pas on a deux vrais sujets moi je
pense que aussi on a abandonné l'italie
sur certains sujets je pense notamment
sur les migrants je pense qu'on n'a pas
été globalement courage ou jeudi on sait
les pays européens je pense que la
france comme d'autres auraient pu
peut-être avoir un peu plus de
compréhension pour ceux qui se passa et
si les italiens ont longtemps réagi sur
ce sujet ce n'est pas que par hasard
mais il ya eu un vrai sentiment d'être
abandonnés ça nécessite une politique
européenne que certains états ne veulent
pas mais pour que ceux qui la voulaient
ils ne sont ne se sont pas fait beaucoup
entendre non plus et je crois qu'il ya
eu aussi ça le fait que l'europe
certes elle n'était pas la cause de tous
les maux mais quand il y avait un besoin
elle n'était pas forcément au rendez
vous je crois que ça a pesé à tout le
paradoxe c'est que on ne parle que des
questions économiques là depuis que
la présentation de ce gouvernement a eu
lieu notamment savoir si l'italie va ou
non sortir de l'euro alors même qu'on
avait le sentiment que la campagne elle
elle s'était joué sur l'immigration ou
plus exactement contre l'immigration ce
qui a fait le succès notamment de la
ligue a c'est vrai que c'est très
paradoxal mais parce que pourquoi on ne
parle que des questions économiques
c'est parce que ce sont précisément les
questions économiques qui ont conduit
les européens et les pros union
européenne à hauteur de l'italie à
s'opposer au premier gouvernement ce
n'est pas du tout la question des
migrants on n'a pas entendu les
partisans de l'union européenne
s'indigne et de la politique migratoire
mais c'est vraiment le noeud du problème
c'est que les le gouvernement italien
même si son programme est un petit peu
baroque il remet en cause totalement le
libéralisme économique qui prévoie une
antenne c'est ça le problème en fait
c'est pas c'est pas la question des
migrants faut partager ce point de vue
g20 troupes qu'en fait bruxelles pour
être simple d'ailleurs les allées enfin
à la fois la commission européenne les
alliés européens de l'italie se
préoccupe plus de l'avenir de la zone
euro que du problème de l'immigration
oui parce que c'est le problème le plus
urgent par rapport à ce que disait le
premier internaute il a parfaitement
raison
en fait le pire service qu'on puisse
rendre à la ligue et à 5 étoiles c'est
de les laisser gouverner plus
s'appliqueront leur plombe leurs
programmes mois on alimentera ce
sentiment qu'on a en france depuis le
rejet du traité de maastricht de déni de
démocratie que l'europe se fait contre
les peuples et qu'ensuite les
gouvernements font leur petite cuisine
dans leur petit leurs petits pots pour
reprendre une expression célèbre et que
du coup
mouvement populaire il est forcément
anti européen évidemment il faut qu'il
puisse gouverner et gouvernés pleinement
et c'est absolument normal que les
premières décisions ou intentions qui
inquiète l'union européenne concerne
l'économie parce que sur les migrants
que voulez-vous que l'italie fasse de
plus que ce qu'elle fait déjà alors
qu'effectivement on l'a complètement
laissé tomber quand je dis on ne s'agit
pas de l'union européenne et des états
qui la composent parce que c'est très
facile de demander à l'europe de tout
faire il lui reprochait de ne pas en
faire assez
plus exactement le reprocher d'en faire
trop quand on veut se débarrasser de la
popularité de certaines décisions parce
qu'il fascine c'est l'analogie avec ce
qu'on a vécu il ya il ya quelques mois
quand barcelone a commencé à faire
sécession pas si vous vous souvenez mais
il y avait l'italie du nord qui disait
mais moi je vais bien et finalement
pourquoi je ne ferai pas sécession avec
le reste le reste du pays
est ce la catalogne comme la catalogne
et se commence à ceux à se dégager pays
par pays forcément deux ou trois pays
dit aux trois pays différents et on le
voit bien déjà eu en france où qu'on
aille le président maquereau et le
président de ceux qui vont bien
le président des villes le président des
riches président de la croissance
puisque ça il ya le reste est donc on
commence à voir même en france c'est
déjà cessé de ces deux plaques là en
italie
c'est très clairement comment dire le la
plaque de ceux qui ne sont pas de
l'italie du nord qui a évidemment gagner
et en grande bretagne c'est exactement
pareil
attention à ce que attention à ce que ça
ne contamine pas la france on a posé la
question aux internautes du figaro c'est
la question du jour sur lefigaro.fr le
nouveau gouvernement italien anti
système est il une menace pour l'europe
il ya un peu plus de dix mille votants
c'est pas un sondage indique que sur la
base du volontariat et c'est plutôt non
il ya une majorité qui n'est pas
écrasante mais qui est quand même net
pour le nom je vous donne encore des
réactions en vrac d'internautes à peu en
colère
pourquoi le vote des citoyens fait il si
peur aux pseudos élites qui vivent par
un site d abobo nous dit le drapier
eh bien oui c'est ça
conf confort ce que vous disiez benjamin
grange quant à john il nous dit qu'il a
été dérangé par la déclaration de bruno
le maire de quel droit se met donc du
vote des italiens
ça c'est une allusion aux déclarations
du ministre de l'économie français
qu'effectivement faisait part de son
inquiétude juste après les élections
bruxelles est en rupture avec les
peuples avec toujours plus de demandes
de faire des sacrifices
soupire marie moi j'ai une question un
peu bête à vous poser ce que vous pensez
que l'europe est en danger en vrai
danger aujourd'hui ou est ce que c'est
juste
on va dire un orage de plus comme elle
en a connu tant adriana tout ça peut
être un danger parce que contrairement à
la grèce il ya trois ans l'italie peut
pas être balayé d'un revers de main
c'est la 3ème économie ça se nommera les
membres fondateurs de l'europe
moi je pense que les italiens alors ils
sont pas ils sont quand même loin de
sortir de la zone euro mais si c'est le
cas et ça peut arriver
l'europe peut s'effondrer on voit que
les allemands sont un peu paniqués
d'ailleurs l'action richard gastout
petit mot là dessus et pourquoi pas une
menace pour l'italie d'abord avant
d'être une menace pour l'ordre si
finalement les résultats ne sont pas au
rendez-vous et que le programme tel
qu'il est proposé avec beaucoup
d'annoncés très peu de moyens n'aboutit
pas ne change pas concrètement la vie
des gens on va retourner sur une menace
d'abord pour les italiens avant d'être
une menace pour l'europe
j'espère qu'on va reparler de ce sujet
et que ça n'est pas fini on revient en
france pour parler du nouveau nom du
front national qui va s'appeler
rassemblement national pourquoi
j'utilise le futur parce que la décision
doit être entérinée aujourd'hui à 19h30
après l'annnonce du résultat des votes
des militants
alors là l'explication classique c'est
le dire que le front national change de
nom pour se dédiaboliser pour être plus
acceptée par le système est ce que c'est
efficace
est-ce que c'est rassurant entre
guillemets ce changement de nom écoutez
ce qu'en pense le député du gard gilbert
collard lui-même front national il a
quelques doutes voire même plus sur les
faits de dédiabolisation d'un nouveau
nom je dis bon je voterai le changement
de nom pas risque lui de camaraderie un
jeudi mais vous
leur et la diabolisation et continuera à
exister parce qu'elle est un processus
politique
les adversaires ont besoin de la
diabolisation pour se réconcilier contre
nous regarder darmanin quand on lui
demande
mais pourquoi vous avez rejoint ma croix
contre le front national
wauquiez contre le front national et
ainsi de suite bon finalement on permet
à toutes les mauvaises consciences de se
donner bonne conscience je devais
trouver la raison gilbert collard le fn
même renault rebaptisée restera le
mouton noir de la vie politique tout le
grand méchant loup
il a raison ce qu'il décrit c'est ce que
laurent bouvet le social le philosophe
sociologue professeur politologues
avaient appelé la stratégie du castor
c'est la gauche castor elle n'existe que
parce qu'elle fait barrage
en tout cas qu'elle prétend faire
barrage au front national et c'est vrai
qu'en ce lutteur de de confusion sur le
programme sur les clivages fondamentaux
que sont le libéralisme
le rôle de l'europe la place de l'état
il faut quand même avoir des choses à
dire au peuple qui élisent leurs
dirigeants et leur dire nous combattons
le front national ça tient lieu de
discours
est ce que le rassemblement national va
désamorcer cette précieuse source de
fédérations ça des partis je ne le crois
pas en plus il ya toujours un problème
avec les les noms de partis politiques
qui expriment des attentions des
objectifs plutôt que des idées ça
rappelle un peu toutes proportions
gardées l'union pour un mouvement
populaire être unie et être en mouvement
est populaire
je ne connais pas parti qui ne
souhaitent pas l'être il suffit pas de
le dire pour le devenir
les chabbiha change quelque chose
changement de nom en tout cas ça évoque
trois choses d'abord ça change de nom ça
se change pas forcément le son du front
national puisque on va avoir des
discours qu'on a déjà entendu même si
finalement le nom va changer est pas
rassurant c'est pas rassurant c'est de
la continuité l'histoire du front
national est en fait celle de trouver
les moyens du rassemblement que ça et le
nom rassemblements tels qu'ils nationale
ça rappelle plein de choses ça rappelle
en 1986 1988 à l'assemblée nationale on
avait un groupe politique s'appelait
front national rassemblement national me
semble-t-il
c'était la tentative de jean marie le
pen déjà d'élargir les bases du front
des bases du front national on a eu la
même chose avec l'union patriotique à un
moment donné qu'il n'a pas pu réussir
qui a abouti au divorce entre bruno
mégret et jean marie le pen
on a eu plusieurs tentatives qui sont
celles de comment on arrive à dépasser
le plafond de verre comment on arrive à
avoir des alliances pour le front
national parce qu'il sait bien qu'au
deuxième tour il n'y arrivera pas la
déclaration aujourd'hui de nicolas
dupont aignan disant qu'on lui
opposerait pas un calendrier rappelle un
petit peu déjà la tentative très réussi
qui va être celle du changement de nom
on peut dire derrière que le front
national rassure finalement c'est le
rassemblement mais on reste nationale
la flamme on parle et l'italie tout à
l'heure qui est un héritage du mouvement
et messi en italie elle reste et les
fondamentaux restent donc finalement
j'ai l'impression que la quadrature du
cercle est en train d'être réussie par
le front national il faut changer mais
pas trop il faut donner des gages à ceux
qui veulent rester ce qu'ils ont été
tout en ouvrant avec le mot
rassemblement est ce que ça fait une
stratégie gagnante aujourd'hui
pas sûr mais pour autant il faudra
regarder mais ça rappelle vraiment les
soubresauts et les tentatives
d'élargissement qui parcourt et qui sont
l'histoire du front national depuis sa
création 72 benjamin quand on sait que
les sympathisants front national sont
traditionnellement assez actif sur les
réseaux sociaux ce sujet là ça les
intéresse et les autres français aussi
d'ailleurs
alors je vais d'abord rebondir sur ce
que ce que vous dites effectivement pour
moi ça change quand même pas mal de
choses
cette ce changement de nom parce que
c'est un c'est un peu la stratégie de
l'oubli c'est à dire que il ya eu dans
le passé du front national la fois des à
foix des départs il ya eu l'échec aux
élections présidentielles et donc on
sait très bien que un nom véhiculant du
sens ramenant à l'imaginaire est bien le
fait d'en changer est aussi un moyen de
se réinventer
/ / / quelque chose je pense je pense qu
elle il aurait dû le faire il ya très
longtemps et que là c'est un peu tard
c'est un peu tard pour le faire il
aurait fallu pour est mort composé plus
vite post réélection aux élections
présidentielles donc
donc voilà c'est quelque chose d'assez
classique
après ce que ça va dé diaboliser est ce
que je dirai les français sont dupes de
la manoeuvre
pas du tout si la régie veut bien mettre
7 7 il eut cette illustration qui est en
fait le résumé à travailler mais voilà
les émotions à travers les émaux j ce
que ceux qui résument finalement le
sentiment sur les conversations
ça se passe de commentaire c'est
effectivement le rire ça fait sourire
donc personne ne se prend ne se prend là
au jeu et donc c'est presque une des
premières fois où je serais d'accord
avec gilbert collard ça ne va pas
changer grand chose quant à la
dédiabolisation et on s'en remet à damas
tout c'est un tournant c est un c'est
rassurant c'est une forme de
normalisation rassurant moi je pense
vraiment que les gens qui étaient déjà
effrayés pour le front national
le seront tout autant par le
rassemblement national et que ceux qui
pensent que c'est un parti qui s'est
normalisée et qui n'est plus extrême
droite continueront le penser après
c'est intéressant de voir que marine le
pen en tout cas c'est ce qu'elle veut
faire la normalisation de ce qu'elle a
proposé à nicolas dupont aignan de faire
liste commune aux européennes je pense
vraiment que c'est assez cosmétiques ce
changement de nom peut-être pour les
gens qui n'ont pas connu le front
national et qui vont voter pour la
première fois aux européennes et
éventuellement
et enfin il faut pardon je ne faut pas
juste passer à la trappe
les changements que marine le pen a
effectivement réalisé par rapport à la
période de son père et est aux manettes
moi je ne connais pas une déclaration
raciste ou antisémite ou contre la
religion musulmane en tant que telle
qu'elle est qu'elle ait fait depuis
qu'elle est arrivée à la tête du front
national dont il faudra faire comme si
tout était pareil ça c'est un rapport à
son arrivée en fait c'est la difficulté
d'avoir un changement dans la continuité
est d'ailleurs le nom de traduit parce
que là foyer de cette espèce d'héritage
parce que le logo reste mais en même
temps il faut aussi d'exprimer de la
modernité toujours dans le rassemblement
avec son devient voilà rassembleront
devant un rassemblement on laisse le
dernier mot aux internautes à marie qui
a l'air d'être assez favorable à la
cause
en tout cas marine elle est vraie et
sincère elle et pour le peuple
macro et les autres c'est tout le
contraire tandis que martin marteau
c'est peut-être un pylône et nous dit
l'anti fn c'est quoi maintenant
les idées du front national passe dans
presque tous les autres partis puisque
l'opinion publique les adoptent et bien
c'est votre point de vue chers
internautes c'est tout l'intérêt de
cette émission
passons à un autre sujet qui n'a
vraiment rien à voir emmanuel macron a
réagi vivement aux décisions
à la décision plus exactement du
président américain donald trump de
taxer les le l'acier et l'aluminium à
porter d'u l'union européenne mais aussi
du canada et du mexique
condamnation qui a été l'occasion de
dire tout le bien qu'il pensait du libre
échange
on n'entend plus beaucoup ce genre de
déclaration en ce moment c'est pour ça
qu'on a décidé de vous la faire
réentendre
je pense que cette décision
elle est non seulement illégale mais
c'est une erreur à plusieurs égards
c'est une erreur parce qu'elle répond à
des déséquilibres mondiaux
internationaux qui existe
de la pire des manières c'est à dire en
fragmentant et en faisant du
nationalisme économique et commerciale
le nationalisme heures
c'est la guerre comme disait françois
mitterrand devant son dernier dans son
dernier discours au parlement européen
nationalisme économique qui mène à la
guerre trèbes matou est ce qu il a
raison la emmanuel macron de sonner le
tocsin comme ça en disant ça y est la
guerre revient pas du tout à mon avis
moi je reconnais pas du tout la pensée
complexe du président dans ce genre de
phrase je trouve que pour le coup le
côté nouveau monde là ça fait très
années 90 c'est un peu religion du libre
échange
le protectionnisme c'est la guerre c'est
une phrase qui n'est pas du tout
justifiée historiquement si on regarde
y'a aucune corrélation entre des
politiques protectionnistes et la guerre
donc là je pense qu'on est vraiment dans
le côté idéologique des manuels macron
qui ne cesse de dire qu'il est
pragmatique mais là pour le coup c'est
une conviction on ne sait pas trop sur
quoi se base sur ce qu'il à être
ensemble un peu parce que la phrase de
françois mitterrand sur le nationalisme
s'était pas en l'occurrence me parlait
patois du protectionnisme il parlait pas
d'économie n'étiez pas d'aimer
il y rendent hommage bien sûr à la
construction européenne est la
pacification de ce point de vue là
d'ailleurs on peut faire un lien avec le
sujet qu'on n'abordait début d'émission
un bon ennemi c'est connu ça permet de
resserrer les rangs vous avez peut-être
remarqué qu angela merkel a réagi
exactement sur le même registre
et là on quitte la référence à françois
mitterrand qui emmanuel macron c'est à
dire en disant ah les décisions de trump
sont illégales de on va riposter et
riposté en saisissant l'om sait que
emmanuel voit bien qu'on veut réformer
en tout cas il va en modifier les règles
de fonctionnement pour les rendre plus
efficaces
paradoxalement ce qui est une épreuve et
sur le terrain économique pour l'europe
peut se révéler politiquement porteur
d'union et les cimenté alors peut-être
qu'on rattrape ce soit pas sur une
grande cause humaniste mais comme il
semblerait que l'économie mobilisant
davantage les énergies et susciter et
exacerbe les créativités mieux que les
causes humanitaires
si ça permet à l'europe qui vraiment
s'est dit lui en ce moment se morcelle
de se réunir contre un ennemi commun qui
est sur le terrain économique de la
halle tron ça peut être positif
et pour illustrer ce que vous voulez
dire on va écouter tout de suite le
président la commission européenne jean
claude juncker qui lui aussi annoncé des
mesures sévères comme d'ailleurs le base
le premier ministre canadien justin
trudeau qui lui aussi est victime de ces
mesures puisque je vous le rappelle la
cieemg lignum canadiens sont également
taxés avec une boîte de 25% par les
états unis comme vient de l'annoncer
donald trump puis en hausse quant à
kaddour tous les acculer de sel
hystérique septembre voilà deux ans il
est colère là justin trudeau réaction
richard bouygues moi je pense que l'on
peut analyser enfin je vais revenir sur
ce que dit trudeau mais d'abord c'est
une décision qu'il faut aussi et d'abord
peut-être regarder à l'aune de la
politique intérieure américaine
on est déjà dans le processus des
élections de mi-mandat et donald trump a
besoin de donner des gages à un
électorat le sien auquel il a dit demain
je vous rendrai les éléments de
croissance d élément de fierté et du
travail et en taxant comme ça à
l'aluminium et l'acier européen et puis
celui de l'alena pour aller vite
en fait on s'aperçoit que si sur
l'électorat globale aux états unis ça
n'a pas d'incidence sur l'électorat
républicain celui auquel trump a besoin
aujourd'hui de s'adresser ça marche il
ya des analystes aujourd'hui à 40 ans
elle en est d'autres qui en gros montre
très bien que c'est vraiment un propos à
destination aussi d'une politique
intérieure le fait est que dix ans ça on
sait qu'avec trump on a quelqu'un qui
est un danger pour certains les accords
internationaux qu'aujourd'hui la
politique intérieure pèse plus que ce
qu'est les risques et les impacts en
matière de politique étrangère
pourquoi trudeau réagi comme ça il est
le premier impact et le canada par les
mesures
c'est en gros le celui qui va le plus
commercer avec les états unis celui qui
fournit le plus en termes dassier est
donc c'est celui qui va être aujourd'hui
le plus impacté normal que ça réagisse
et du côté de l'union européenne aussi
ce qui veut dire que pour l'europe on
peut entendre qu'il y ait une volonté de
réagir
simplement c'est quel moyen et là je me
dis il ya peut-être une occasion mais
une occasion de faire quoi avec qui et
en se mettant d'accord comment parce que
si c'est uniquement le coût du manteau
en disant que c'est difficile et que
falloir réagir mais on réagit pourquoi
et comment l'idée c'est que peut-être
qu'à cette stratégie de trump il faut
pas opposer la même stratégie mais
peut-être sur d'autres choses mais
compliquées avec un partenaire qui a
bien montré à plusieurs égards sur
l'accord de paris sur le nucléaire bien
que finalement les accords
internationaux pèse moins que la
politique intérieure aujourd'hui aux
états unis
alors vous disiez que peut faire
l'europe est bien elle peut déjà porté l
affaire devant l'organisation mondiale
du commerce qui est le gendarme du
commerce international c'est ce que
vient de faire la commission européenne
ça n'a d'ailleurs pas échappé à wendake
lee qui nous dit attendons
tranquillement ce que dira le mcs qu'en
feront trump elle est présidée le
président chinois
et puis il ya deux réactions
intéressantes de nos internautes crise
bourbon qui dit à meymac rhône
n'avait-il pas infléchi trump lors de
son déplacement à washington and on me
dit on il est ironique notre ami crise
l'inflexion c'est la version
communication pour les français
autrement d une fake news
quant à survêt il nous dit tout ce qui
dérange leur idée est illégale alors il
sait se dit libre échangiste imagine le
vote des italiens maintenant la décision
de trump etonnant non
benjamin grange votre point de vue sur
ce sujet ben c'est pas trop mon point de
vue que celui des français que l'on a
écouté mes passes ratées revers lors des
nombreuses conversations et c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve le propos ce que vous
avez cités c'est que les français sont
un tantinet critique sur les prises de
position du président macron challenge
le fait qu' il réagit un peu après la
bataille
ce sujet de la taxation de l'acier n'est
pas nouveau le président trump ne fait
que mettre en exécution quelque chose
qui l'avait annoncé et d'ailleurs il le
fait avec un tout petit sursis puisqu'il
avait laissé il avait laissé un léger
mois donc la question que se posent les
français c'est pourquoi lors d'une
visite de la visite diplomatique du
président macron n'at-il pas aborder le
sujet et n'a t-il pas eu de résultat et
ça rejoint si vous vous souvenez la
semaine dernière un sujet qu'on avait
déjà traité qui était que penser du de
la visite du président macron en russie
et en fait les français challenge cette
forme de diplomatie de la poignée de
main ou ça se passe bien il ya de très
jolies photos mais il se pince il ne se
passe pas grand chose derrière
si on prend un peu de hauteur et mat ou
est-ce que l'édition de tram c'est pas
finalement manifestation de plus que ce
que vous disiez 7 ce libre échange en
fait il est remis en question par tous
parce que c'était aussi la base de la
construction européenne séduire la libre
circulation des capitaux des hommes
et puis là ça coince de plus en plus
riches et les corps avec vous
quand j'entendais judith dire que
l'europe pouvait peut-être s'unir sur le
libre échange
je constate fed en tout cas qu'elles
avaient des réactions après l'organe de
recours c'est évidemment l'om sait
puisque c'est l' omc qui transforme la
balle à base de toute relation
commerciale c'est à dire le rapport de
force que c'est tombé comme un cas de
force s'est commandé 400 civilisé avec
des règles oui mais c'est tellement
décalage avec les aspirations des
européens on le voit dans toutes les
élections aujourd'hui moi je trouve que
vous éviterez en retard d'une guerre on
est vraiment en retard d'une guerre là
on est on essaie de se rassembler tous
sur le libre échange comme si c'était
par principe une idéologie génial qui va
tous assurer l'harmonie entre les
peuples
pour le coup je pense que trump pour le
coup comme d'autres états d'ailleurs a
compris qu'on avait changé de paradigme
il fait du protectionnisme et peut-être
que justement ça pourrait être
l'occasion pour l'europe de faire son
protectionnisme à elle parce que c'est
toujours empêchés de le faire jusqu'à
présent on était un peu les dindons de
la farce mais c'est toujours empêchés de
le faire par dont précisément parce que
l'allemagne parce que tire une grande
partie de 200 de son pib de ses échanges
avec les pays extérieurs à leur
détriment des autres pays européens
sherbrooke si ringard le libre échange
non mais je trouve que le débat s'est
pas ou d'un côté le
le libre échange ou de l'autre côté
espèce de guerre commerciale entre
maintenant en train de dire on va pas
non plus loué la manière dont
aujourd'hui donald trump traite ses
principaux partenaires qui sont la chine
avec la sanction sur en gros les 25 %
taxe sur les produits hautement
qualifiés qui va en gros peut causer un
problème il le fait avec le mexique
il le fait avec le canada il le fait
avec l'europe en fait c'est les
principaux partenaires des états unis
sur lesquels ils tapent aujourd'hui on
peut pas dire non plus qu'il fait d'une
manière particulièrement élégante et
quand il le fait c'est pas forcément
comme ça on a envie d'imaginer le
commerce au 21ème siècle
ou alors ça veut dire que derrière on va
être dans des mesures hyper mercantile
mais en fait prises par les régions
elles mêmes avec leurs propres intérêts
et plus du tout deux logiques sur un
niveau de régulation internationale moi
je pense qu'il ya quand même entre le
libre-échange et puis cette guerre
commerciale il ya peut-être un moment
donné un échange réciproque du commerce
réciproque
il faut réinventer les règles réinventer
les règles de la mondialisation
probablement et l'europe là un rôle à
jouer
par contre dire qu'à un moment donné on
est contraint d'être sur les deux
polarités là je suis pas d'accord je
vais être un peu aujourd'hui c'est un
peu ça je vous donne deux les points de
vue des internautes
tiens mâcon vient de découvrir que le
libre échange n'est pas le pays des
bisounours peu dit johanne tandis que
gérard a besoin
quid de maquereau qui surtaxe les sens
effectivement ça c'est pas lié au libre
échange et et trump qui sait que
l'europe est une machine lourde et peu
efficace nous dit béatrice effectivement
il ya on va voir si elle arrive à ceux à
se mobiliser tout en ayant d'autres
chats à fouetter
quant à moi là dessus on s'est tous dit
bon et bien on s'est tous dit alors
heureusement on a encore plein de sujets
passionnants à traiter et celui là en
particulier
gérard collomb le ministre de
l'intérieur était auditionné avant-hier
par le sénat il y présentait la loi
asile et immigration et il a fait cette
déclaration choc si ce n'est choquant
regardez puis je vous dire monsieur le
président qu'il n'ya pas que le sénat
qui fait du benchmarking mais que les
migrants aussi font un peu de
benchmarking pour regarder les
législations à travers l'europe
c'est choquant cette déclaration adrian
matou pas tant que ça finalement
peut-être qu'il ya une forme de vérité
dans ce qu'il dit dans le fait que les
migrants avant de faire leurs voyages
choisissent les pays qui sont les plus
accueillants mais moi je considère qu'un
iso l'inter doit maîtriser son
expression choisir des mots peut-être de
ne pas emprunter au lexique du marketing
pour désigner d'une situation humaine je
pense que voilà peut-être que sur le
fond il n'a pas totalement tort mais il
ya un prennent d'expression publique qui
en plus récurrent chez gérard collomb le
coup et bottes le fait exprès je crois
qu'il est qu'il est il a une formation
supérieure ens lettres n'ont peut-être
que judith finalement n'est ce pas
mettre en cause son approximation sa
sémantique défaillante il sait
exactement ce dont ils parlent
mais rappelez-vous d'ailleurs c'est
cette polémique là avait déjà été lancée
par nathalie oiseaux
quant à lui parlé de shopping en fait
après rapide vérification on s'était
aperçu que c'était le langage utilisé
dans les documents anglophone y compris
par les organisations humanitaires
voient là on rappelle que d'emprunter
l'oiseau c'est la ministre aux affaires
européennes et ce shopping c'était le
fait pour les migrants de choisir le
pays où ils voulaient arriver en europe
voilà en fonction de critères d'accueil
de possibilité d'exercer une profession
de regroupement familial etc
donc c'est exactement du benchmarking et
esther benbassa à l'époque sénatrice
europe ecologie les verts avaient crié
très fort contre nathalie oiseaux est en
fait finir de s'offusquer de la forme
elle exprimé un désaccord de fond pour
une certaine partie de la gauche une
certaine la totalité des airs
mais aussi une certaine partie de la
république en marge de la majorité qui
l'a dit à l'occasion de la loi asile
immigration
il faut accueillir tous les gens qui ont
fait l'effort de venir en france dans
décès dans des circonstances périlleuses
il faut pas distinguer les réfugiés
économiques c'est ce qu'a dit nicolas
hulot en disant qu réfugiés économiques
c'était une expression qui le donnait un
sentiment de malaise et au jeu revient à
votre question d'où l'utilité de gérard
collomb gérard collomb est un homme qui
viennent du parti socialiste de l'ailé
droite du parti socialiste certes mais
de gauche dans le gouvernement
macron c'est quasiment ce qui se fait de
plus à gauche et grimper grâce et grâce
à ça même s'il ya eu grâce pendant et
protestations il a réussi à faire passer
un texte très dur et dans lequel la
droite
malgré ces critiques se reconnaissaient
assez sûr sur l'asile et sur
l'immigration donc c'est sa valeur
ajoutée politique c'est pour ça qu'ils
venaient le mcu lui permet cette liberté
d'expression à mon avis moi j'ai ma
manche choquant pas choquant cette
déclaration
les français sont vent debout voilà
devant c'est tf1
face à cette expression on est
typiquement dans le politiquement
incorrect
alors évidemment c'est les as toutes les
associations qui tiennent la dragée
haute et qui font en sorte que les
conversations s'animent en disant oui
c'est totalement scandaleux
et puis quand on creuse on s'aperçoit
que il ya de plus en plus je ne sais pas
je les jeunes aient qualifié l'arrêt je
ne jugerai pas qu'ils disent finalement
il ya peut-être un peu de pragmatisme
il est peut-être un peu de pragmatisme
au niveau du comportement des migrants
et c'est pas si choquant que ça puisque
finalement ils choisissent une autre vie
que d'aller choisir le pays qui est le
qui est le plus le plus accueillant
en complément de ça moi je voulais vous
faire part du riz smart personnes que
j'avais eu parce que j'avais jamais
travaillé à une dizaine d'années sur le
retour volontaire sur la communication
comment faire en sorte que puissent
communiquer le retour volontaire qui
était un sujet qui était très qui était
très épineux voilà déjà qui avait
immigré en france est venue de rentrer
chez eux de là encore contre qui avait
été refusée en tout cas en tant que
réfugiés et donc se poser la question de
savoir si on pouvait pas les
raccompagner dans leur pays et donc dans
l'étude de deux je dirais d'aider des
leviers de la manière de poser la
communication on avait interrogé des
migrants qui était arrivé sur le sol
français et puis des migrants dans leur
pays d'origine et dans plusieurs pays
d'origine et on s'est aperçu que
finalement il y avait une image du
migrant qui était dans le dans son pays
d'origine match de la france qui était
bien plus haute que la réalité
en fait il ya vraiment cette image de
d'aller chercher un eldorado que tout
est facile que finalement on va une fois
qu'on a fait le voyage qui est par
contre très éprouvant très dur et bien
on arrive sur comment dire un territoire
qui va permettre une nouvelle vie et
puis quand on interrogeait le migrant
qui était sur le territoire français et
qui venait en plus de se faire refuser
comment dire ça c'est l'égalisation sur
le sur le territoire et bien lui c'était
un désenchantement le plus complet parce
que il ne trouvait évidemment pas du
tout ce qu'ils avaient ce qui avait donc
ça ne m'étonne pas que on est ce ce
sujet là parce qu'il ya un vrai sujet de
la perception finalement des pays
d'europe dans leurs capacités finalement
offrir une nouvelle vie au niveau des
populations qui espèrent qu'ils espèrent
qu autre chose fait fabriquer les chocs
compte pas choquant sa déclaration
vous imaginez bien qu'elle m'a beaucoup
plu c'est parce que vous augmentez le
même parti que gérard collomb pour ça il
ya très longtemps et je pense qu'on a pu
les mêmes lectures de jaurès mais bon
peu importe
vu qu'il a beaucoup cité je pense qu'il
devrait replonger dans certains jours
non moi je pense que c'est une saignée
expression qui est inappropriée c'est
une expression qui est choquant et dans
le benchmarking
il n'a pas choisi les mots par hasard
gérard collomb il a échoué
des mots pour taper pour provoquer pour
piquer mais ça veut dire quand même qu'à
un moment donné on donne une image des
migrants parce que c'est pas d'un
migrant ou d'une catégorie d'entre eux
qui pourraient s'adonner à ça mais on
donne une image des migrants qui me
semble à un moment donné complètement à
côté de la plaque par rapport à la
réalité de ce qui est vécu et regarder
encore les actualités aujourd'hui des
personnes qui vont migrer parce qu'elles
sont détenues en esclavage d'autres
parce qu'elle suit la gare de prospecter
sur les destinations non mais les gens
qui sont à calais le disent qu'ils
veulent être passeur d'angleterre mais
pas rester en france certes mais pour
autant dire qu'on fait du benchmarking
comme si on avait une espèce de d'un
catalogue et une brochure de tourisme
dans lequel on va aller se pointer
franchement c'est pas comme ça que ça
s'est passé quand les gens risquent leur
vie
les traverses tous les pays tels qu'ils
le font à un moment donné c'est l'espoir
d'arriver ils savent pas forcément où il
arrivait ils ont pas forcément choisi la
destination dire qu'il ya une attente
sur quelque chose ailleurs oui parce que
c'est ce qui fait aussi enfui et qu'on y
va bien évidemment mais de là à dire
qu'à un moment donné on est dans des
logiques de benchmarking sur le
directeur des ventes l'a bien il ya un
côté qu'à un peu choquant moi j'entends
que les associations qui travaillent
clients aient été choquées par ce monde
il n'est pas du tout adapté et surtout
on avait eu
vous l'avez dit nathalie l'oiseau qui
avait eu cette expression qui avait
suscité la polémique à l'époque remettre
un peu une expression similaire
c'est remettre à un moment donné l'huile
sur le feu dans sa soeur des
organisations humanitaires qui font
qu'ils font du secours aux migrants qui
l'utilisera vous chasse parce que
c'était utilisé dans le texte oui mais
bon c'était pas dans la compassion pour
eric ciotti dans ce sens alors c'était
dans des documents à lui elles n'ont pas
dit dans une édition comme celui-là est
dans le moment à qui est ce
oui mais pas dans cet esprit là
franchement je donne ma réaction des
internautes
gabriel qui nous dit que l'on a raison
et tant pis si en disant la vérité il
dérange certains autruches qui auraient
préféré rester la tête dans le sable
gérard lui s'indigne ce n'est pas les
migrants qu'il faut cibler mais les
réseaux de passeurs
l' esclavage qui est la double peine de
ceux qui viennent pour fuir l'enfer et
se retrouvent piégés par des exploiteurs
tandis que plurielle 59 tout dit
appelons un chat un chat
n'en déplaise aux aficionados du
politiquement correct est-ce que
l'émotion soulevée par cette cette
expression c'est pas aussi fait que chez
certains responsables politiques ou
associatifs
on voudrait traiter le problème des
migrants sur un registre purement
émotionnel et pas du tout rationnel et
le fait que les migrants puce est dans
une espèce de stratégie ils ont tous des
téléphones mobiles et c'est bien normal
et que donc ils peuvent probablement
contacter leurs proches qui sont dans un
pays ou dans l'autre que montrer que
cette migration est organisée c'est une
façon de dire ce n'est pas cette espèce
de mouvement irrésistible de survie
qu'on décrit par tous est ce que je me
trompe
vos réactions
non ma réaction était plutôt sur la
forme parce que effectivement sur le
fond peut-être que c'est pas faux de
dire que y'a des stratégies chez les
lions et c'est ce même sans doute un
petit peu vrai voilà
mais il arrive un message d'accord il
faut être mais si on analyse froidement
les choses on va juste comparer un
ancien ministre de l'intérieur qui est
bernard cazeneuve dans son expression il
n'était pas accusé de ne pas accuser
d'être en immigration liste vous ou
quelqu'un vous il était chirurgicale
précis sobre là gérard collomb il a
quand même l'impression d'être
approximatif et c'est pas la première
fois quand il dit dans les
manifestations les black blocks et casse
tout et les manifestants qui sont à côté
devrait intervenir
franchement je ne sais pas comment ça
valait que c'est calculé
parce que si vous avez calculé c'est
machiavélique un mois je crois que je
vous ai expliqué ce que j'en pense c'est
que il bénéficie d'une liberté de parole
d'une marge de manoeuvre qui est assez
rare dans ce gouvernement qui est plutôt
verrouillé par emmanuel macron parce
qu'il ait valeur ajoutée politique
venant de la gauche et est ce qu'il dit
tout haut ce que macro pensent tout bas
vous croyez détendant temps oui qu'en
mélangeant ce sujet là quel est votre
intime conviction adrien matute
journaliste politique vous suivi ça de
près je pense qu'il est d'accord une
façon ils avalisent toutes les décisions
ils le pensent peut-être un peu plus
poliment que gérard collomb mai
et sur le fond ils sont assez d'accord
après c'est vrai que effectivement c'est
plutôt un pont un atout pour emmanuel
macron d'avoir un ministre qui vient de
la gauche qui tient sans doute le
discours le plus à droite de tous les
membres du gouvernement et du cycle avec
à droite discours le plus à droite à
gauche
voilà finalement après moi je trouve que
ça dure que sur la forme ça pose
question et notamment quand on voit la
majorité il ya quand même 115 députés en
marche qui ne sont pas allés voter la
loi asile immigration certains sont pas
venus d'autres se sont abstenus
il ya quand même être un sujet gérard
collomb qui va se poser au bout d'un
mois je jouais pas totalement pas tant
mieux comme ça il ya des cols douala
parce que il est compréhensible que
quelqu'un qu'un migrant qui veulent
changer de vie imagine ou en tout cas
choisissent les pays où il a envie
d'atterrir ça paraît ça paraît normal
après donc après ça ça nous ça nous
renvoie là l'expression de gérard
collomb ils auraient dit les migrants
choisissent le pays sélectionne les pays
identifiés les pays qui à la limite je
pense serait beaucoup moins fait réagir
il a utilisé un vocabulaire quel
vocabulaire de l'entreprise qui
finalement comme on sélectionne les
différents différents produits dans une
entreprise et c'est ce parallèle là je
pense pas qu'il soit fait inconsciemment
il a voulu faire réagir derrière ça donc
donc je poserai enfin je poserai pas le
l'hypothèse que c'est que c'est un acte
maladroit non il a voulu faire réagir
oui il ya cette idée derrière que
finalement sont les décisions qui sont
très rationnel qui s'est pas juste un
réflexe de survie chez les jeunes
migrants et donc est donc derrière la
réponse qu'il est en train de proposer
doit être une réponse toute aussi
rationnelle et non plus dans
l'émotionnel comme on a l'habitude de
traiter ce genre de sujet non juste sur
le est ce que le ministre de l'intérieur
est présent la république sont en lien
j'aime beaucoup les déclarations de
laurence rossignol qui se croient ont
été très clair en montrant qu'il y avait
un lien entre les deux donc j'en parle
c'est une ancienne ministre socialiste
qui est aujourd'hui sénatrice qu'elle
était très pertinente dans cette dans
cette approche
après sur encore une fois
j'ai l'impression en fait qu'on mais
avec cette expression qui effectivement
est fait pour faire réagir et elle le
fait elle fait même réagir dans le
propre camp du président de la
république les déclarations de gabriella
talent sont complètement
vous allez dire atténuantes et se
démarque de ce qu'a dit gérard collomb
des députés l'argentine un mois à peine
couverts la déclaration du non dit la
critique tel quel en disant qu en gros
le benchmarking c'est entre mourir sur
place et partir je le caricature à peine
ses propos il sait pas si on a progressé
passion d'habitude et c'est pas
exactement son expression habituellement
en compte on à benjamin griveaux plus
castaner qui derrière passe pour essayer
de faire le service après vente de
l'explication du pourquoi il a dit ça
finalement c'était pour les passeurs ce
n'est pas pour les migrants que c'était
pour concrètement on voit bien qu'il ya
eu à travers cette expression un espèce
de malentendus au sein de la majorité
est-ce que ça c'est organisé aussi je ne
pense pas à telle que cet organe donc
oui ça a suscité pour quoi s'acheter des
mois parce que on a dit et on voit qu si
on a des migrants qui fuient la guerre
et que ces migrants là c'est pas des
millions qui choisissent de la même
manière que ceux qui sont peut-être avec
des projets avec vous là il ya aussi ce
qui suit il ya ceux qui migrent pour des
projets sait pas exactement la même
chose et mettre tout le monde à un
moment donné derrière cette idée du
benchmarking pour tous
c'est ça qui est je crois un moment
donné choquant et encore une fois il
n'ya pas que des migrations qui sont
liées à la suite de la guerre dans le
monde il ya des millions de migration
tranquille 36 millions de migration qui
sont volontaires on parle pas de celle
là là on parle de gens qui sont poussés
à choisir parce que il ya la guerre
parce qu'il ya la famine parce qu'il ya
des réseaux qui sont là un moment donné
pour profiter exploiter ces personnes
donc c'est cette espèce de
généralisation est comme si on était
avec des gens qui étaient dans encore
vous l'avez dit mais des stratégies
d'entreprise alors qu'il ya des
stratégies de survie et gabriela talent
avait sur ce coup-là raison je serais
d'accord avec lui sur ce point je
propose de laisser le dernier mot
plein de sagesse à johan qui nous dit
pourquoi n'y at il pas de discours
serein sur l'immigration en france oui
c'est vrai ça n'est sans doute pas près
d'arriver
on a beaucoup de chance ce soir d'avoir
quatre intervenantes qualité
et en plus un spécialiste du football
c'est richard bouygues alors c'est un
sujet un peu hors procès verbal mais
vous n'êtes pas obligé de donner tous
votre point de vue là dessus je vois
jerry weintraub qui s'affolent parce que
le football c'est pas sa spécialité
heureusement c'est celle de richard
bouygues entre autres et coup de
tonnerre hier
zinédine zidane qui annonce que il
renonce à entraîner le real de madrid
est ce que c'est pour faire autre chose
est ce que la france a besoin dit dan
comme a dit le président de la
république
moi je suis pas dans la tête de zinedine
zidane n'a par ailleurs rien accédants
celle de john malkovich mais enfin moi
je suis pas dans celle de zinedine
zidane
zinédine zidane arrivé à un moment donné
où il fait trois coupes trois ligues des
champions
il a été vainqueur une fois du
championnat il a une équipe qui arrivait
un peu au bout
il va falloir la modifier va falloir
faire des recrutements son management
cette année a été bon mais il a été
aussi un petit peu chahuté il est au
fait de sa gloire il se retire
moi je pense qu'il fait un voilà il fait
un bon choix il part au bon moment il
part avec les honneurs il paraît que les
vole au ras
il a été un excellent joueur il est un
excellent entraîneur il se retire il
n'annonce pas où il va il le fait de
manière plutôt sage est posée et là tout
d'un coup par contre ce qui est
surprenant c'est layton et layton et
layton qu'on en fait à côté espère qu'
il ya un phénomène zidane qui dépasse le
simple fait qu'un entraîneur fasse une
conférence de presse pour annoncer non
pas une catastrophe
ils arrêtent d'être entraîneur d'une
équipe il pourrait en entraîner d'autres
le ce fait-là fait que tout d'un coup il
ya un écho et ça prouve quoi ça prouve
que ce joueur incarne quelque chose et
qu'il a une résonance particulière en
france fait la même chose avec plein
d'autres entraîneurs savent une
conférence de presse qui fait un flop
lui ce quelque chose de très fort
quelques jours avant une coupe du monde
c'est pas forcément dans un calendrier
qui est maîtrisé mais sa voix qu'est ce
qu'il va faire derrière je n'en sais
rien il ya plein d'hypothèses on dit il
a envie de l'équipe de france si
l'équipe de france ne fait pas de bons
résultats ce qu'on ne souhaite pas en
russie on verra certains disent il ya
une stratégie et jean par exemple il ya
une stratégie pour certains de dire il
est peut être aussi tenté par finalement
des organismes uefa ou fifa et l'uefa
dont il va y avoir des élections
prochainement
est ce que c'est ça sa stratégie
d'autres qui disent que peut-être il a
un contrat qui l'attend au qatar pour le
moment on n'en sait rien toutes les
conjectures son sont ouvertes à voir en
tout cas
moi je suis pas médusé mais un peu
surpris par l'écho démentiel de cette
conférence de presse mais qui me
confirme que avec zinédine zidane les
choses sont toujours un peu plus
extraordinaires en écho que pour tous
les autres
est ce que la france a besoin de
zinedine zidane mais il a déjà montré
qu'il a bien servi la france me
semble-t-il
obama tout mon petit doigt me dit que
vous avez beaucoup le foot oui il va au
design à votre avis c'est quoi votre
scénario alors moi non plus je ne suis
pas dans la tête de zinedine zidane mais
je pense que ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
met une énorme pression sur didier
deschamps puisque là il est disponible
tout le monde parle de lui comme le
successeur de didier deschamps à la tête
de l'équipe de france
et même quand il était au réel on en
parlait déjà donc là pour didier
deschamps qui en plus est un petit peu
en fin de cycle à part à part gagner la
coupe du monde va pas beaucoup de
d'options pour rester eh ben didier
deschamps le message est passé vous avez
intérêt à être performant en vous attend
en russie avec votre équipe
ça commence quoi dans quinze jours c'est
ça la coupe du monde c'est ça c'est ça
bon eh ben on s'en est sorti pourtant le
football ce n'est pas ma spécialité à
moi non plus
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission point de vue c'est fini pour ce
soir mais ça revient lundi même heure
même endroit très bon week-end
[Musique]